oui c'est promis toujours si je mange
bien d'en faire à l'est parisien
je peux vous aider mais fait peur ce mon
job
vous aviez pris rendez vous etc torsac
ce contrôleur des normes
j'arrive toujours à l'improviste c'est
mon job
l'étrave est ce que ça existe vingt dix
ans ce type est un animal et un
contrôleur qui plus est les gardes tu as
fini de faire ton intéressante
monsieur saxe
j'en avais trop fait qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de vous dis ça c'est un lugar 10
sacs qui s'étendent en pire c'est un
quoi bonjour à tous je vais trouver des
investisseurs chez les humains
vous avez quinze jours pour rendre ce
pack le plus effrayant qui soit alors si
non vous savez tous ce qui vous attend
qu'est ce qui nous attend on va tous en
enfer
on n'est pas déjà rêvé de conduire deux
mois ce corps dont ses oreilles du thé
do l'invite du père
elle est grave et d'égal que la housse
de plan à son groupe
et voilà pour être battus 5 pour se
servir de cette machine bon allez à plus
quand je pense que j'étais fan
[Musique]